We've broken down non-predictive data
analysis in the four categories,
geospatial, segmentation,
aggregation and descriptive.
Let's talk about each category.
First, what is geospatial analysis?
This type of analysis
uses location-based data
to help drive your conclusions.
Some examples are identifying
customers by a geographic dimension,
such as zip code, state, or county.
Calculating the distance between
addresses and your stores, or
creating a trade area based upon your
customer locations for further analysis.
Some types of geospatial analysis
require the use of special software,
such as software that can convert
an address to latitude and longitude.
Or software that can calculate
the drive time between two geographic
points on a map.